he and Austin congratulations your hard
work has paid off and you guys are
moving into the third and final round of
this super size competition in this
final round you're going back to your
home forces for four days building
iconic weapons of History bladesmiths we
want you to build this
the Japanese great sword
the Japanese Greatsword Rose in
popularity during the 14th century
reaching lengths of up to five feet long
this massive single edge slightly curved
blade was designed to deliver deep
penetrating Cuts upon enemy soldiers on
foot or on Horseback alike
while this enormous weapon became too
impractical for battle by the 17th
century it can still be seen in many
action films including the classic 1954
carasawa movie Seven Samurai
good luck gentlemen we will see you in
four days
my name is Austin Frakes I'm 37 years
old from a little town right outside of
Houston Texas I'm a sergeant with the
local police department over my
professional career I've seen a lot of
the ugly side of life and a few years
ago I picked up bladesmithing after
watching forged and fire I like to make
beautiful knives this thing is
absolutely ridiculous it's huge it's
obscene almost a foot to go in length
hoping I can get it to Links quickly and
get this thing quenched as quick as
possible it's right in between the two
parameters
almost like I played
the Heat Treating process is going to be
difficult due to the extreme length and
the fact that I've only got an 18 inch
long Forge
we are skating I know the blade is good
and hard happy dance
all right that's enough of that
I am putting on faux not real alligator
skin to give this sword a little bit of
my Texas Heritage down here on the dirty
Third Coast everything looks good so far
now it's just time for the handle wrap
just trying to make it so that it's not
uncomfortable for the judge's hands my
hands are now cramping severely as I'm
doing this nearly 21 inches of braid as
I finish it up I think it looks pretty
cool
it just needs an edge and then it's test
time I did grind the blades in and I'm
hoping that the lighter weight and the
thinner profile will help it cut better
while still being thick enough to retain
its Edge during the damage test
whoa
foreign
I'm 19 years old and I'm from the small
rural town of Bedford Pennsylvania
probably what got me started making
blades was just my dad being a carpenter
we made a lot of wooden blades and I
looked at him and I said wouldn't it be
cool with this with metal and he's like
let's do it all right so we are pretty
much at length to where I want to be I'm
pretty much done and I'm ready to get it
up to temperature and quench it so my
gas forge isn't actually big enough to
do the Heat Treating so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to dig a ditch and
make a kind of like a redneck coal Forge
I have the blade in there I'm just
watching the temperature and just making
sure I don't overheat it things are
definitely heating up literally
it's hardened I am really happy with how
it came out sweet
so next thing I need to do is I need to
shape this handle and get it actually
ergonomic and feeling good in your hands
because this handle is pretty big all
right it's starting to fit my hands
really good I really like it it is now a
fully functional sword this thing is a
beast so I got the cashier put on uh
it's shaped I really like it I am ready
for um yeah making it look cool I start
wrapping this handle it's going really
nicely a brown and black contrast is
awesome it's starting to look like a
finished product
there we go very nice fit
cool
placements welcome to the dynamic kill
test
that's what great disappointment that I
have to say that I will not be able to
wield your weapons to test it but Dave
Baker will be enjoying and doing your
tests Ian you're up first you ready for
this go for it
foreign
[Music]
so Ian right off scale wise perfect for
my hand the wrap is really well dialed
in your blade every single one of those
cuts it was deadly your Edge is still a
razor blade it lost no Edge whatsoever
nicely done thank you all right Austin
you ready yes sir
foreign
[Music]
Austin right off your sword has a lot of
height to it and it's got a lot of Mass
to it but it's really nicely balanced
which I like an issue there are some
dull spots on your blade dull enough
that I can run my finger back and forth
on it but I really like the look of this
blade actually done thank you
all right blade Smiths welcome to my
Dynamic test the steel wind chime and
fish slice
Ian you're up first you ready for this
not really
well get ready it's coming
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first things first I'm impressed this
Edge doesn't really show much of any
indication that had been smashed into
steel wind chimes you know you could see
the cuts on all these fish are nice and
clean the handle wrap is really
comfortable the dimensions are good all
in all nice job thank you
all right Austin you're up man how you
feeling let's get it over with all right
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right Austin well you're all in one
piece well done where I was hitting the
wind chimes each time I hit them you
lost more and more of your Edge there's
some rolls I can get a fingernail
underneath so as I was progressing
through the fish they became more and
more difficult to cut through but all in
all I think you did a great job thank
you
boys miss you both impressed us the
entire competition but at the end of it
only one of you can come out on top earn
the title of Fortune fire champion and
check for ten thousand dollars today's
Fortune fire Champion is
Ian very well done Austin unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut and
Doug's going to tell you why
Austin what it came down to is the
darling you took during our test it just
underperformed on the dynamic kill and
sharpness test and those are the reasons
why you didn't win today I agree
completely
so Austin it's been an absolute pleasure
watching you pound steel in the Forge
and come out with two massive blades but
unfortunately your time this competition
has ended we'll say thank you for coming
out but I'm about to ask you to please
step off the fourth floor thanks y'all I
don't like to lose but Ian's great got
to lose two that definitely makes it
easier
well Ian congratulations man that makes
you a fortune fire Champion you'll be
getting a check for ten thousand dollars
very well done
I'm so kind of in shock still a little
shaky but really excited I'm really
thankful how you feeling Bud pretty good
thanks thank you guys not people that
I've met be knowing what I can do in
such a short amount of time it's just I
learned so much